[Music]
there comes a time
in every player's career when they have
to put it all on the line for a chance
to win
big they're all together ppd here comes
the ice blast ready for the dog
[Applause]
a moment where they throw caution to the
wind and
simply hope for the best is in between a
rock and a hard place and now
zed they already have the information
they know he's around house rc's dies
no one's on bomb yeah honestly someone
could hop it you just force the bat gun
fight zed with the necks and now you
can't you gotta hunt this man down flat
oh my god
you cannot do that and sometimes
those gambles have spectacular payoffs
nitro does have a model of another smoke
so it could be really rough or simple to
actually get through this he's going to
throw the awp
oh my god simple
but there have also been infamous
moments when players didn't need to put
anything on the line and still chose to
risk
everything the arrest of former blizzard
world champion
lee life seong hyung has been followed
with an indictment
people's careers have just been ended
today by volvo gaben
gaben has come down and struck multiple
people
he has smite a match fixing is the
ultimate sin
in any competitive arena and
unfortunately esports
is no stranger to it it's a greasy
dishonest act that can not only destroy
careers and
ruin reputations but even result in a
loss of freedom
it's no laughing matter and everyone
found guilty of it has faced serious
punishment
well everyone except the one guy whose
only punishment
was a meme that he'll never be able to
live down
nowadays you might know a lexi solo
berezin as one of the best
dota 2 players around he's a five-time
major winner and one of the most
successful russian esports athletes of
all time
not just major champions but you're the
mvp
voted for by people watching the talent
have had a hand in it as well
come on man you're the best player thank
you
a man of few words the mvp once again
please put your hands together
for solo as the mvp but in spite of his
achievements
in the game solo's not exactly someone
who enjoys staying in the spotlight
and for good reason see back in 2013
before solo's trophy cabinet was full of
major titles and his garage was
overflowing with german luxury vehicles
he was just beginning to make his name
and during his time with rox kis
he made a catastrophically stupid
decision
that nearly cost him everything prior to
his match against
z rage at star ladder star series season
6
solo placed a 100 bet against his
own team's success and to ensure an easy
payday he played like he'd never
played before literally
yeah ooh hook shot i mean it's on a
creep only they actually want to try to
go in with this bcd
it was already very low to begin with
three seconds solo as well
they just went in here to die what's up
with that i don't want to say it's
impossible for us to come back but
you'll oh
he's so dead why is he standing here i
don't know
now obviously a game with a ridiculously
high kill count and
flagrant feeding was going to draw
attention and it wasn't long after the
match that
evidence of solo's shady wager began to
surface
uh
upon their discovery starladder swiftly
dished out
hefty bands to solo and his teammates
for their assumed cooperation
but eventually the sentences were
lightened to essentially a slap on their
wrists
now you'd think that solo's winnings
would be some tremendous amount of money
considering the risk he was taking but
it turns out that he put the future of
his promising career on the line for
what turned out to be a
measly 322 dollars
it wasn't long before the number 322
became a widespread dota 2 meme which to
this day gets spammed in twitch chat any
time a suspiciously bad play is made in
game oh
this is problematic ember spirit can now
jump for the templar assassin
really caught out does some decent
damage but hulk shot
why do i feel that was unnecessary
by all rights solo's dota career should
have ended then and there
and it would have had he not begged and
pleaded with the community for
forgiveness
following his apology starladder
shortened solo's lifetime ban
to a single year and sanctions against
his teammates were lifted completely
and since then to his credit solo has
completely turned things around
he spent the last seven years building
an impressive legacy as the captain of
one of dota 2's most successful teams of
all time
he's living a comfortable life and
because of his achievements he's become
a
celebrated russian figure now in spite
of his best efforts to
shake the moronic mistake of his youth
322 is a brand that solo will
never be able to erase so why is that
well solo remains a source of
controversy across
all of esports because he's the only
player that valve has ever led off the
hook for match fixing
you see solos was the first known
instance of
match fixing in dota 2 and at that time
because valve didn't really have a
playbook
for handling situations like this they
were fairly lenient
but others who repeated his mistake
wouldn't be as lucky going forward and
the consequences of solo's action
would go well beyond dota 2. a year
after the 322 incident
cs go was hit with arguably the biggest
match fixing scandal in the game's
history when i buy power's talented
roster
blatantly threw a match at sivo season
5.
i gotta say the entries are looking a
little weak from iraq power along with
the strats i mean they're just doing
very basic things they're trying to just
fully attack these sites and
not really using any smokes or pop
flashes for the most part to their
advantage and it's very
unlike them it will be a two versus four
bomb plant a
and we're going to see hazed in cutler
cutler is going to peek out and steal
his right here with the cz
doesn't go for the shot he's going to
try and get the flank off he's going to
have two right there can they line up
for him
what is he doing why did he hesitate so
much doesn't matter has this easy gets
one
gets taken down hayes was so very low
they lined up perfectly for him but for
some reason oh he says he wanted the
knife
it's very weird to see steel opting over
skadoodle
i don't know if skadoodle is not feeling
it right now or what is going on but i
buy power is definitely not playing
like i buy power when details of the fix
finally came to light
one of the most promising rosters north
american cs had ever produced was
slammed with permanent bans from valve
sponsored events
effectively ending everyone except
skadoodle's hopes
of achieving anything noteworthy in the
esport
i think valve took their shame of having
this happen in their game and they've
deflected a lot of that onto either
power and used them as figures of hatred
as well
to deflect all the negative energy onto
them that some of it should be involved
in the fact that they allow these things
and the fact that they don't have a good
system in place to decide how people
would be punished
the most shocking of the bands was that
of brax
a prodigy who looked to be the future
face of north american counter-strike
a young talent whose career was
completely derailed because of a single
poor decision
i think it's a very sad history that he
can't compete anymore for me it's a
little bit too harsh
for what happened and for being the
first time it ever happened
get [ __ ] days sorry bro you're the
ringleader you should burn
and i'm just so sad that you [ __ ]
brought swagging this [ __ ] with you
that you took advantage of a [ __ ]
young star that was that had everything
ahead of him
and that he could he could have [ __ ]
gone on to become one of the best north
american
players of all time to [ __ ] dominate
worldwide and you ruined that
so [ __ ] you you need to burn and while
brax
was still capable of participating in
non-valve organized events
his career opportunities were ultimately
stunted
it didn't matter how good he was or how
much the community rallied behind him
no organization in their right mind
would ever pick up a player who could
never compete at a major i felt uh
just stuck i guess in a way probably
like a year ago
up until i signed with t1
i didn't really feel like i was
achieving anything or going anywhere
that's right after being left in limbo
for years
brax threw up some deuces to valve by
signing with t1 as their first pro
player in riot games's
valorant even though it wasn't meant to
be for brax and
counter-strike it's hard not to think
about how his career
might have panned out had even given a
second chance
like solo instead of treating each case
on an individual basis
valve continues to wield the ban hammer
with indiscriminate force against anyone
remotely involved in match fixing
incidents
but no matter what your stance is on
valve's brand of justice
the fact remains solo is an anomaly
he's the one match fixer that actually
got away with it
and that's something that fans and a
meme will never
let him forget he has always been with
us
always watching
always but whatever your opinion of solo
is
dota is all the better for it since
making his illicit little wager
solo has blossomed into literally one of
the greatest
captains drafters and support players
the game has ever seen
he commands the respect of his teammates
ramses or solo
[Music]
oh now that's some team love yeah he's
nodding he's like that's how it goes
that's how it goes you trained him well
he invokes the
ire of his opponents ramsay's ranch
trying to fight
managed to eat his way through the trees
shinku can't quite see him just spot him
out now managed to get the healing south
and they actually get the kill on the
reekie
pyw he's trying to go for the calendar
but it gets descent back and now he's
plucked in
solo with the double kill outplay and he
has spearheaded the success of one of
dota 2's all-time
fiercest rosters
[Applause]
when it comes to match fixing and the
bans that usually result from it
communities are often forced to mourn
wasted talent
solo is perhaps the only true case in
esports
of someone who screwed up got away with
it
and made the most of his shot at
redemption
he's given esports a reason to believe
both in him
and second chances at large to remember
that people
can learn from their mistakes rectify
them
and become the force for good they
always should have been
20 20 like 12 like if you were around
for 2012 2013
it's a good time dude it was like the
pre-teens
of esports it needed to grow up you know
what
that is the actual analogy here like
2015 was like
you know the real coming of age like the
like you know
18 goes off to college right like
but and now we're like in the maybe you
know the early 20s we're in like the
actual
like you know life lifespan of esports
now but [ __ ] 2013 was like the was
the pre-teens like that was like this
15 16 years old cr cringy is all hell
but goddamn was a great